The
next excerpt is taken from original tape W. one
hundred
would you go to school with. Oil.
And wood to school at Beech Grove until I was in the fifth grade and it was a three room school project only
a hundred children and it burned when I was in
the field grade. So then they moved me to one bigger school
head possibly twenty of them and they were prof with four hundred students going
there and then I went to break the time I
was a sophomore after school. Now I'm on the neighborhood use course.
Finishing Maskell to prom. So are you actually yes I have taken
to the GED in our last eighteen points having met a plumber great to learn how to
get point where I go
back and I take over you know what part. There's five parts to the
TS what parts have made the lowest down and then have the tag team or extra
point. To the action to right now it's in that image for problem. What do you
like
to do with that I may go on to college or
then
if they want me to work on his lab or the wheel.
Was a couple years ago you talked. Yeah. Why did
you drop that was what you need
to know a year at Nassau more years it just gets rough on me I had six
of Jackson just as tired of going to school.
What about your sister
says I have a vow when school and Canada have but one sister is
a complete high school. And his work in over the jury by a nail.
Corso diploma Hendon her very much because she didn't were going to years. That I'm as
of brothers and sisters just went to high school
quit her that your mom did the school.
The other was school in the county but they didn't get their house going to palm of my mother was great
and my father went to the field. Ingrid. He works on.
The operation maids train
repairing houses is a really fun.
Yeah. So the
OIO that. Are there are a lot of projects.
Yeah. There isn't in life they know it's Neighborhood Youth
Corps operation main string and emergency
food and. The sample you notice right.
To his Nephew is their job problems.
Here they are. And if all we see they're talking Beckett Now I know and if they
are you if they do this Gormley was very bad I knew people here if you can with that
job. What do you think.
There's no wind because I mean there's no weather thing
formative if they can I don't think you know
because those. Most of them are you know middle aged and they're not a
lunatic old age and they're not really that. Sickly to get a
phone disabled. And then they're not well enough to get a job in the factory.
So some people are saying to the daughter just you know you should
build factories
or yeah people can change. So people can have subject wishes and like
this neighborhood use course you we don't haven it's H.K. ship to get you know
good job. There's fifty seven of us some in the neighborhood you
school to do that they pay you for the work that you do or do they give you extra money.
Yeah they pay us bad the air we get dollars sixty an air and
that we're allowed to work twenty three hours a week no more than twenty three hours a week and then
or six hours of school we go to the other yeah. So we get
twenty and pairs in a week and we get paid over two weeks.
What do you do you have
a share of books or card through that process because I do just
anything the average do it. Slip that out ordered goods and
that kind of thing. Do you think you might want to go on.
Yeah. Yeah I think that I'd like to go on and take library
said that's right just like I want to do I worked when I was in grade
school high school I was worked on I thought you know that I just you know you
are teaching. But now.
When I had never I never worked in a lab or in any of the really got to go in and enjoy
every until I started to have school because in grade school we didn't have a library and
adding given that you know what a lot of us lacka to after the Had school. And then I didn't use it
that marriage and I didn't know how to use a card catalog had no sense no kind
of experience with the average check I'm over here and I go
on to college work.
Yeah it will. If you're real and I've been here eighteen years and
I've enjoyed every bit
of it and had your family but they lack
of the I think it's great
to because they you know because I have picked up so much since I have been here you know.
Just from watching them were. In what they tell me you know.
You know really picked up a lot
of things. What about you because your dad worked on Operation mainstream work.
You know my mom didn't work. You know she's she's sickly you know she's not real
this able but she sickle she has heart
trouble and my mom's. Fifty
three you know did it to one.
What she did before friction.
Worked in the coal mines and talked a lot of
people there and then before I worked in the coal mines he worked in
Newport your factory personal
pride in it seeing Campbell County
in there he was to stand there about it and then
you have people like their parents
or a dog a father in a coal mine accident.
You know. Are you hearing trouble there. But now
my grandfather was blown up in the coal mine. That. He lived to
be nanny
six and he's only been there three years and you know he get well no
but he had rocks in his legs and thing you know and with the skin and he ended
up having a woman's legs taken down
off. You know was thankful that he lived as long as he
did your good.
Man What good will that grandfather was married
six times. And I never knew. I mean. And they've been at the same
at grandma my real grandma. But my step. Grandma still living.
In there that I never did remember my grandma and then I'm on Meadows sad and me of the
didn't and they would say
my grandpa grandma or her said You mean
great grandpa telling about
things when he was growing up
you know anybody get to associate that much with my grandfather. You know
because he was sickly and he didn't help for image and maybe you know got associate with him
that
message. Of Herman dad you know dollars after Mommy say
that to him back when she was the only
one to week that was on Sunday morning every you know every other morning they
called Brit.
And I can remember my daddy a talkin about have they have to work in the court
of appeals. He has fought for fifty cents a day
before. And had after walking away and out
to work. And I was raised in a hole. About three
miles off the road. We'd have to walk into school
now and just learn our path and for her to good you know good so it
would flatten the creek courses somewhere that were funded. You know but then in the waiter
we gladly create a new just bet for you to days before you don't get to
go to. Card.
Yeah we had a garden in weekend in the garden and we tended to back
till after all the family got away from home but now we don't you know we distilled our Nam
but we don't
think. We own the whole have been how. I was in second
grade when we moved in starting raining and we waited
for rap fag years then we Banus another piece of
land and we found their other
home and made a T.V. all around home now he started in
August moved in in December. He did all the work
you set him and my brother. And we've been living relieve a nail
six years and we have with completed rooms basement.
And will get inside there in the waters and my dad. Don't know
his work is if you work you know every day our public
doesn't know how to do it. Yeah the
market repair. Yeah he knows you know dental work you say
I accept Now he did do is plumbing my brother did that to
your brother poor and now his new head of it he says he's working my
bread with. Behave this new head of it he's not a
plumber that he didn't pour. The family business together.
Do
you think you know.
Yeah you have a severe home until something happens you know we'll leave there.
What
about Is there room for your kids you know. Money.
Oh yes they have well wants to we they have a college
young people's maybe. And they run this to a vein around pick up the M. People in
the taken to the church and they play games and they have that has been that kind of
thing is this is your area
right now because now this is the primary upon
canoe and I've Sebastian's braincell No not this people operate on their own.
And that they know here in Tehran they hit the send thing you know. And they
have some go to the G.M. the new bridge drive
by and that kind of thing to do
with the church. Yes the church as a church
than to say
it. And now they have. The little preacher drive or you
know
takes you know in this way
you know.
Yeah but can you. That's the way they move. And then you know don't seize and
they have ballgame and they come to
you. And they have the races to be heard about the right number they have you know
their peers. Sabayon farm. They have a racetrack in that last week they have a
racetrack course you know car
races and they involve all they have a racetrack for
horses and a lot of people go. All up there at
near to savin farm over the last semester but they say that
it's really crowded. But they want it to have been just the dirt
track in the wanted to ask you to give like they say it's really nice and they have
the blog to share our knowledge
thankful but I've never been there every morning to go but they save this. The appeared
to be a new name and. Yeah. That have been their last
Christmas it's really
nice their. What about.
You might be different. Right.
About. You know
you get. That when you notice a difference between.
Yet I must. There is a preacher. Oh yeah he's been a preacher for twenty two years.
He's a baby's preacher doesn't preach. Yet he still preaches. But he didn't
have the last and to marry people you know but he preaches. Yes you can preach a good choice of usin
the baby.
Descend. Yeah but he didn't have a radio program read things like that he preaches funerals
and things. He preaches there recently and were alley and.
We gave him a fart up in the holler for church and they build
the
church you know in we hear the pastor live
descriptives Kentucky until he
died and then he dad and then we got a pastor from of huge drug
brain B.S.
grow. Where my parents leave it sort of just girls out of
hell you know how we feel about Brief births they do want us to worry says you know me you
mean that they don't require just
one of those mixes. And they don't care for was dating
boys you know when we get to around age say seventeen
eighteen but they you know just and they live it. They wanted to found out about the boy before we go
out with them you know that kind of thing they just want to go out with any boy.
And they're not too strict of their you know strictness an alley here
one sister that's been the one church and no member as is
the preacher.
Yeah it really is because you know most around here anyway because most of the same
life
do join a church and know that we don't need
doing or get out and we re on you know we stayed home and
that means we listen to what they tell us you know this to
better protect church can assist you. But we
go you know to cheer when my mobile church we go to church. But you know we don't
hit we never even be able
to do anything. And this is.